how you doing i'm doing how are you
doing that's the question
yeah yeah i'm doing very good it's a
very good wednesday over here
very good must be a pretty cool way to
uh
i don't know to celebrate the day what
was your first reaction when you got the
nomination when you heard
honestly i was i was literally i'm at
the moment
london is on lockdown so i was in the
mid i was
in the kitchen doing like a little like
kitchen workout circuit
and then i and i like everyone is at the
moment home workouts
my phone started like going a bit mad
and i was like what's going on over
there
and looked and saw um saw that the show
had been nominated and l had been
nominated and then i saw that
like potentially i'd been nominated and
i was like have i really and i kind of
like
did some did some googling i guess just
to make sure that was definitely the
case but i was just
um i was just so happy honestly i was
like um
i have such a fun time on this show um
tony mcnamara is an incredible writer
and he's created something that's so
wonderful and
peter is such a brilliant character to
play
um but also l fanning um is the
the most perfect wonderful catherine and
she brings that character to life
um in a way that i admire so much and
i'm i'm so proud of her as well so i'm
just uh yeah i'm very excited that
the show's getting um recognized in this
way
and that you're getting recognized too i
mean this is your this is
the first time right that you're being
nominated for a golden globe
my first time yeah which is um it's it's
wild you know
the first time i went to the golden
clothes was when i was 12 years old with
um
with about a boy um so you know
19 years on or whatever it is um
yeah i'm very honored and and feel lucky
and grateful that they've
they see what i've done as being has
been
recognizable i guess against er like
the other guys nominated in this
category it's very cool i'm i'm yeah i
feel very lucky
it's one thing to be nominated um for
your own performance which is an amazing
thing but for the show to be recognized
and also your co-star to be recognized
it really means that they saw the show
as something
very special is that how you felt when
you were making it did you know like
this is going to be something that
people are really going to
connect with and really love you you
know i hope so whenever you're making
something whenever i
uh um become part of something it's
because i really care about it um
and particularly with tony's writing i
think it's it's very smart it's
very relevant to what's happening in the
world today um
and i think also it's just something
that that speaks to people there's
always this
this slight thing where you can watch
historical pieces
um currently and kind of see the
similarities between what's happening
perhaps
but see them in a way that's kind of
mirror or reflected and
and um makes it easier to palette and
understand was it still being
a little bit of an escape you know um
and his writing is so smart in terms of
being really gut-wrenching at times and
powerful but also being very fun
um with very smart dialogue on on on the
surface of it so it makes it very
enjoyable to watch
um and we honestly just had the best
time making the show so um
i feel very very lucky
you know you're it's funny you had
alluded to you know what we're all doing
right now
staying at home you've got your homework
out going on
i think it's i think it's interesting
the fact that we're all at home and
our sort of patterns for watching things
have changed a bit you know we
we're always interested in what's
happening with the movies but i think
right now particularly what's happening
with streaming
shows tv shows and series people paying
a lot of attention to you do you think
that the way that we are
um taking in entertainment now
especially due to the fact that we're
all sort of stuck at home has
shifted the focus a bit yeah of course i
mean i
i wouldn't say it shifted the focus
completely from films to tv but
obviously i mean
everyone at home and then and they need
they you need an escape like you know
one of one of my favorite shows one
is shit's creep um but one of the things
i'm also really excited about being
um nominated this year is that dev patel
and daniel kahlu got nominated as well
because
those guys you know i started off doing
skins with when we were 16 years old
so to to see them get nominated um and
for us all to kind of be able to
celebrate the same year is really
exciting
and also i think that their performances
in in the movies that they did
are just phenomenal so i'm very proud of
them
um obviously you know we're not going to
get the typical golden globes
party which is a very fun thing to watch
on tv but also this sort of opens up
uh new opportunities to celebrate in a
different way you just mentioned the
guys that you kind of started out with
all being nominated together do you
think that you'll make plans
with l with even those guys to sort of
celebrate online
while this is all happening i mean if i
if i can definitely and obviously olivia
coleman as well
um so it's a there's so many people that
i know and love and are so
so wonderful and i've had um the luck to
work with over the years that have been
nominated this year that um
i'd love to celebrate with if there's if
there's an opportunity somehow
um i don't really know how this is gonna
work to be honest with you but um i'll
probably be sat
exactly here um probably doing this
so um but yeah if there's a way to kind
of uh
enjoy that with friends then i'll be
very happy do you think that you'll um
dress up for the occasion right there in
your kitchen
i will i will dress up yeah why not it
doesn't happen very often so you've got
it right
yeah absolutely have you have you spoken
to ellie yet
i have she's actually on set today so
i've just been texting and saying
congratulations
and how happy i am and how well deserved
it is now
that's fantastic well man
congratulations uh so many things to
celebrate
uh for you this year and right now and
uh
i don't know are you gonna get back to
working out now do you have is it has
your focus changed
i mean honestly that i mean that's
that's kind of the thing i guess when we
finish this zoom i'll just like
this bench turns back into my like bench
bench and i'll
and i'll carry on the workout right on
except you'll be envisioning these as
golden globe statuettes
you're like i'll be calling them yeah
right on
great talk to you man congratulations
thank you so much appreciate it
you